effectivement à tout à l'heure on est
loin des images catastrophe tourné
récemment à bollène edenred angoisse de
la semaine dernière il n'en demeure pas
moins que le sud est est toujours en
état d' alerte maximum
hier soir des pluies diluviennes se sont
abattues sur la côte d'azur bilan
inondations évacuations par centaines
reportage yannick à rossi et didier
beaumont quelques dizaines de minutes
d'un orage très violent et des ruisseaux
se transforme en torrent incontrôlable
ce n'est certes pas la grande
catastrophe mais les dégâts sont
nombreux
il arrive surtout 48 heures après les
inondations de mardi soir résultent
tout est à refaire ce qui avait été
sauvée une première fois et
irrémédiablement perdus toujours on
avait passé le kärcher on a essayé de
sortir les vêtements c'était très
souvent à plat les chaussures etc
et puis on avait lavé toute la vaisselle
tout ce qui était puisqu'on pouvait
pouvoir prétendre arriver pas des routes
transformées en rivières des voitures au
fait tu de paye
le niveau de l'eau est montée très très
vite quand j'ai vu que ça monte ça monte
j'ai laissé la voiture là puis je me
suis placé un charentais dans la station
les orages d'hier soir se sont
concentrés sur le littoral des
alpes-maritimes sur un sol détrempé par
les pluies de ces derniers jours
l'eau est passée là où on ne l'attendait
peur fleuves et rivières n'ont pas
débordé le sol comme il n'a pas pu donc
absorber tout à déboulonner haut niveau
donc des routes principales notamment
aidé des vallons principaux ce matin les
pompiers poursuivent leur travail 300
interventions en ti 400 à 410 à nice et
ici tout le monde restait vigilant
l'alertent météo est maintenu